hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on Borderlands 3 again
and today is gonna be possibly one of
many videos I upload today and maybe
throughout the week as the new
Borderlands event be handsome jackpot
casino has just went live and they're
gonna be dropping a lot of different
legendary weapons and I've actually been
playing for only like 10 to 20 minutes
and have already gotten like four
Legendary's three of them are old ones
like the LOB the magnificent whereas
this current one we're talking about the
Boomer is one of the new ones those a
lot like the B if you doing dress
subscribe for free new let's get started
with covering this new gun so like I
said the new DLC weapon is called the
Boomer and I want to get two things
straight really quickly the weapon I
received is actually called the trained
boomer I'm not sure if that's the actual
name of it or trained it could be the
prefix meaning it changes depending on
what type of things are added to the
weapon certain attachments and whatnot
so just because it says trained boomer
doesn't mean that that's the full name
it could be something else entirely like
something trained boomer or something
boomer I just want to let you guys know
that and also in terms of where I got
this to drop I got it through the new
DLC so you have to basically get to
sanctuary to be able to play this DLC
you can access this at any level just as
long as you have sanctuary and I got it
from my world drop no bosses at the
moment there is no confirmation on
whether this also drops from my boss is
a dedicated loot source but at the
moment I got it from a world drop but if
anything like that changes in the past
do things I mentioned I'll leave a pin
comment with the changes that happen
whether it actually comes from a boss
and etc but the weapon stats are as
follows it has four hundred and forty
nine damage seventy-one accuracy
sixty-eight handling two second reload
11.24 fire rate twenty seven magazine
size and at least for me my magazine
size increases because of the skills I
have for Mo's and in terms of the fire
rate currently it is actually almost as
fast as the [ __ ] SMG so we have a
little contender for very fastest in G's
now the red text says some like it hot
and it comes with Splash Damage radius
weapon fire rate increase and critical
hit damage I'm not actually sure if that
fire rate increase makes it faster than
the [ __ ] SMG but either way it's pretty
damn close to it and then at the bottom
section it says bullets are laced with
hot sauce now this is actually a really
fast SMG
with explosions on every hit I tried it
on with Mo's and Amara and all shots had
explosions no matter what
overall the gun ain't too bad the game
player seeing is mayhem 3 with neutral
modifiers I wanted to test it on mayhem
3 because if it can't do well in mayhem
3 it clearly is not going to do well and
mayhem 4 with the insane increase in
health and armor that the opponents have
so that's why I wanted to test it there
and then move on to see if it's a good
mayhem through weapon but maybe not as
good mayhem for and you know stuff like
that but as you can see it doesn't
really shred armor or shield that much
unless you have certain things helping
you like a shot grenade or some
corrosion going on in the background
then it looks like it is but just as the
weapon itself it doesn't really shred
too much of armor and shield so health
is really gonna be your best option and
it really doesn't do that either
depending on the build you maybe can max
this out a bit more but like such as the
shield of retribution tree for mows but
as it stands now I don't really see that
making a huge difference in my opinion I
wanted to also test two of Moses
abilities one being the Splash Damage
doubling in size I wanted to see if that
counted and then also there's an ability
she has for when she does Splash Damage
there's a 10% chance of ammo coming back
into the magazine so here is that
comparison whether I'm shooting off the
dummy and then on the dummy
see I do it that which you will with
those results like I said it's really
not the greatest of weapons I don't
really see this being an endgame weapon
at level 50 that you're gonna be using
for raids like the takedown and other
endgame bosses but I feel like it'll be
a really nice weapon for you to use
maybe during a playthrough like your
level twenty thirty just trying to grind
up to 50 and you come across the decent
legendary I feel like that is gonna be
where this weapon lies so with like I
said it's not great but it's also not
bad either and let me know what you guys
think about this weapon down in the
comments below I still don't really know
what that Hot Sauce thing means I don't
know if that has something to do with
the DLC at this moment or if that's just
like a funny thing they added because of
the explosions but if that has something
to do with the DLC [ __ ] I might be wrong
about this whole weapon entirely but I'm
not really sure I think there's just
some bogus stuff that they happen to
write down at the bottom just for a
little bit of creative flavor text and
with that guys take care I'll be
uploading a lot more videos throughout
this week as I find new weapons new XP
farms other [ __ ] like that about the new
DLC anything like that just make sure to
keep it locked on the channel we're
gonna be uploading a lot this week or
that guys take care like I said like
three if you're doing dress subscribe if
you're new take care enjoy the rest your
day peace out